hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal
wieder eine leckere torte von mir und
zwar die knopfes regel torte
wer mich schon länger kennt der weiß
dass ich den knopf muss regel über alles
liebe und deshalb musste ich mir einfach
die torte dazu ausdenken und die torte
hat ganz schön was zu bieten denn neben
den zwei saftigen schoko böden und der
mascarpone sahne creme haben wir im
innern der torte noch eine waffel mit
karamell und haselnuss kern den saftigen
schokoladen boden habe ich euch bereits
in einem separaten video gezeigt dass
verlinkt ich euch auch gern noch mal
außerdem benötigen wir waffel blätter
die gibt's in jedem gut sortierten
supermarkt wir benötigen weiße
schokolade vanille extrakt kalte
schlagsahne mascarpone zum festigen
etwas salat und zum süßen puderzucker
wir starten zuallererst mit den leckeren
creme und dafür wird die kalte
schlagsahne in der küchenmaschine oder
auch mit eurem handrührgerät steif
geschlagen damit die sahne auch schön
fest wird geben wir an der stelle unser
sein apartment dazu seiner tat ist ganz
einfach einsame stand mittel genauso wie
sahne steif ihr könntet also auch
stattdessen sahnesteif verwenden denkt
aber dran sein apparat ist bereits
gesüßt und wenn ihr sandstein verwendet
dann müsst ihr auf jeden fall nochmals
abschmecken ob die creme dann auch süß
genug ist weiter geht's mit der
mascarpone die gebe ich ihnen eine
separate schüssel und verlor sie mit den
restlichen zutaten werk ein vanille
extrakt da hat der kann an der stelle
auch einen esslöffel vanillezucker
verwenden
die weiße schokolade habe ich nach dem
schmelzen etwa 10 bis 15 minuten
auskühlen lassen keine sorge die wird
nicht sofort fest ihr solltet sie
allerdings nicht heißt so mascarpone
geben da die mascarpone sonst gerinnt
die zutaten sollten sich dann gut
miteinander verbinden das geht am besten
mit einem handrührgerät anschließend
kommt der puderzucker mit dazu und tier
ist entscheidende wie süß ihr eure creme
legt die weiße schokolade und die sahne
sind ja auch schon süß genug und deshalb
brauchte ich hier gar nicht so viel
puderzucker
wenn sich dann alles miteinander
verbunden hat geben wir nur noch die
sonne unter
auf geschlagene sahne lagere ich dann
übrigens auch immer im kühlschrank auch
wenn es nur ein paar minuten sind jetzt
haben wir das ganze in zwei bis drei
schritten unter und dann ist unsere
creme auch schon fertig
für das runter heben der saane verwendet
ihr am allerbesten einen teig schaber so
könnt ihr garantieren dass die creme
auch schön luftig bleibt die fertige
creme la gericht an dem kühlschrank und
es geht weiter mit unserer überraschungs
füllung hierfür benötigen wir
kämpferisch weißen zucker butter und
haselnuss kennedy habe ich vorher an
gerüstet wir stellen jetzt eine art
karamell creme her eine sehr
vereinfachte dafür geben wir unser klemm
frisch zusammen mit dem zucker in den
topf verrühren das gut und lassen das
auf mittlerer stufe ganz lange köcheln
und grünen dabei immer wieder um
dieser schritt dauert etwas länger
circa 15 minuten müsst ihr am topf
stehen und immer wieder fleißig umrühren
damit auch nichts anbrennt irgendwann
fängt dann der weiße zucker an zu
karamellisieren und das ganze wird
ziemlich schnell braun
sobald ihr dann einen schönen cara
welligen ton erhaltet gebt ihr die
butter mit hinzu und an der stelle den
herd unbedingt ausschalten damit uns da
auch nichts verbrennen kann
wer sich diesen schritt übrigens sparen
möchte der kann auch fertige
karamellsoße verwenden schmeckt auch gut
ist gar kein problem und gibt dann an
der stelle einfach die haselnuss kerne
mit dazu
da die masse ziemlich heiße es gebe ich
sie kurz an die seite damit wir sie auch
anfassen können ohne uns die finger zu
verbrennen und seither bitte ganz
vorsichtig die waffel blätter die jetzt
zum einsatz kommen die habe ich übrigens
etwa zwei zentimeter kleiner
ausgeschnitten damit man sie von außen
auch nicht sehen kann
die karamell haselnuss masse verstreicht
ihr dann auch den waffen blättern und
das funktioniert später am allerbesten
mit angefeuchteten händen
danach gebe ich das zum vollständigen
aus grün in den kühlschrank wer fertige
karamellsoße verwendet kann auf diesen
schritt natürlich verzichten
anschließend gibt es weiter mit unserem
saftigen schoko boden den teile ich
einmal mit meiner torten segen der
hälfte durch
nun stellen wir die knacknuss regel
torte nur noch fertig und dafür lege ich
meinen schokoladen boden auf meine
platte und lege da einen tortenring
drumherum
und auch wenn der schokoladen boden
schon super saftig ist trinke ich ihn
trotzdem immer gerne mit etwas milch ihr
könntet an der stelle zum beispiel auch
kakao verwenden
anschließend kommt darüber die hälfte
der mascarpone sahne creme und wird
glatt verstrichen
darüber lägen wir dann mit ich unseren
waffel kern und geben anschließend die
zweite hälfte der mascarpone sahne creme
darüber hier könnt ihr auch ganz gut
erkennen warum die karamell schicht
unbedingt vollständig auskühlen musste
denn ansonsten würde die sahne creme
schmelzen
abschließend geben wir unseren zweiten
tortenboden darüber und dann wandert die
torte für drei stunden in den
kühlschrank gerne auch über nacht denn
das ganze muss jetzt richtig schön fest
werden damit der boden im kühlschrank
auch nicht austrocknet an der oberfläche
müsst ihr unbedingt für schalte folie
darüber geben
derzeit geht es dann weiter mit der deko
hierfür gebe ich meine flüssige butter
in meine vollmilch kuvertüre und
verrühren das miteinander
die mischung ist noch sehr sehr flüssig
und müsste jetzt ein wenig fester werden
dafür gebe ich sie für 20 minuten in den
kühlschrank und rühre dabei immer wieder
um damit auch keine klümpchen entstehen
dann holen wir die knacknuss regel torte
aus dem kühlschrank und befreien sie vom
tortenring
die glasur hat jetzt eine etwas festere
konsistenz und je nachdem wie kalt oder
kühlschrank eingestellt es geht es
manchmal auch schon schneller und dann
gebe ich das ganze auf die oberfläche
der torte
den seiten lassen wir sie jetzt nur
tröpfchenweise herunter fließend ganz
unregelmäßig mal mehr und mal weniger
solange die glasur noch nicht ganz
ausgehärtet ist geben wir schon unsere
knopfes regel stückchen mit dazu die
habe ich auch ganz unregelmäßig in
kleine stücke geschnitten und gebe sie
jetzt am rand entlang auf die torte
und somit ist die knoppers nuss regel
torte fertig und ihr könnt sie genießen
uns hat sie allen unheimlich gut
geschmeckt
und weil ich mir ganz sicher bin dass
die frage auftauchen wird ja ihr könnt
auf die torte auch den großen bruder des
knopfes riegels geben dass ganz normale
knoppers
falls ihr die torte jetzt nachbacken
werdet dann verlinke ich doch gerne auf
instagram unter dem hashtag ekis kitchen
ich freue mich immer sehr über eure
fotos und freue mich natürlich auch wenn
ihr mich kostenlos abonniert damit ihr
keines meiner videos mehr verpasst und
wir uns auch beim nächsten mal wieder
begrüßen dürfen
weitere super leckere torten verlinke
ich euch hier natürlich auch nochmal und
sagt bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis
kitchen